sanks lintao you have just as seen how
our research in storage and systems has
significantly helped our product teams
to improve the search platform and a
product next I'm going to invite a
senior researcher don't make them to
come to the podium to tell us about the
code clone analysis technology which
again is a piece of research that
highlights how our work helped the
software developers across the company
to significantly improve the way that we
writing software the way we produce our
tools domain thank you for Microsoft is
a software company here we cannot
undersized enough the importance of
software development and tools over the
years microsoft research has made a
tremendous contribution in the area of
software development and tools here's a
video we'd like to share with you to
show our passion and our thoughts in
this area
my cousin is in the business of inner
delivering software so the more we can
understand the software that we are
building the more that we have insight
into the code that we are building the
better job we could do as a company in
terms of delivering great software
technology shifts over time but it's
always the same principles that you can
imply to improve the situation starting
from solid foundations better
programming languages better
abstractions my team is in research
because we are trying to explore the
limits of what we can do with our
technology we develop larger and larger
scale of software and the software of
more and more complexity more and more
data are generated in the software
developers that naturally expands the
scope of software development tools so
the perspective that we have in doing
our research is to take the data to even
approach to try to improve the software
and service qualities as well as the
divine productivity over the years
developer division and Microsoft
Research have worked together and
resulted in some fantastic in
technologies that we've been able to
deliver to a developer customers there
is a dream that we can produce software
that has no security vulnerabilities
that guarantees your privacy and that is
in some sense always available and it's
good to always have somebody knowing the
state of the art and pushing the state
of the art Microsoft has done a very
good job in terms of using data in our
develop process to make decisions but
thinking about where we are and the goal
we want to achieve there's still a lot
of room whar's to do research and
development together with our portal key
partners we want to make software so
immersive that you don't care whether
it's written in one language or another
whether it runs on one platform or
another the main thing is you can use
it in order to improve your life as one
example of our work in the area of
software development tools today I'm
going to talk about code column analysis
people who read code are very familiar
with copy and paste in fact copy and
paste is a common developer behavior
will copy a peaceful code and paste it
sometimes will make changes big or small
sometimes we don't although copy and
paste is a quick and easy way for us to
reuse code it could have serious
consequences when there's a body in the
code the good part will be spread to
other places when the code gets copied
when we fix the bug in the code quite
often we just forget to fix it in all
the copies to make things worse
sometimes we're not even aware of the
copies being made by other developers
when bugs are created like this and they
do not get fixed in time then the
product quality will be compromised in
addition to the bug problem the code
base could be bloated over time as more
and more code gets copied and this will
incur high costs on code maintenance and
Microsoft Research we developed cold
color analysis technique that can help
developers find similar code in
particular when to code snippets are
gapped clones meaning one code snippet
has inserted or deleted statements that
the other code snippet does not have our
technique can handle such clones with
high precision and recall our cultural
analysis technique is scalable and it
works efficiently and effectively on
large-scale code bases in addition we
provide an intuitive user interface for
developers to easily understand
the differences between code clones
based on our code color analysis
technique we have created called clone
search service and transferred it to the
microsoft security research response
center using this service over 400
million lines of code across multiple
microsoft product code bases have been
indexed whenever a piece of vulnerable
code in web version of a product is
identified using this service we can
easily find similar code snippets in
other versions of the product if the
same vulnerability exists then we can
fix it in a proactive way as you can see
on cold color analysis technique helps
make microsoft products become more
secure in addition we also collaborated
with the visual studio team and
integrated cold Colin search technique
into the new version of their studio
which was recently previewed at the
build conference using this new code
column an asset feature developers will
be able to find code refactoring
opportunities very easily and also this
feature will help them fix the same
thought was if the buggy code has copies
with the release of the new version of
virus video we're very happy to see that
I'll call column analysis technique will
benefit the developer community last but
not least I would like to thank our
colleagues the msre innovation and
engineering group as well as our
partners in Microsoft Security Response
Center and also various the routine the
technology transfer of a cold color
analysis is a great example of the close
collaboration between Microsoft Research
and Microsoft product teams this
collaboration demonstrates not only our
passion about technology innovation but
also our determination to make real
impacts using innovative technologies
thanks for attention
you